okay hello everyone welcome to a working
meeting
as part of our incremental language
development series we are looking at a
variety of candidate functions let's
start off with entity queue
and this was spawned a bit i believe it
was a question from a different line
stream which was
we have all of these functions that
operate on entities why isn't there an
entity queue
and
after a little bit of discussion with
the group we've come up with they're
basically three component parts of what
an entity queue might be
there's a structural predicate to say is
this syntactically valid
there's a
registry component in terms of the type
or domain that says you know
do city entities exist to begin with or
is this a type that's invalid
and then the third case
which has some caveats is does this
particular entity i've specified
currently exist
and
i think there are
the first two cases are pretty
straightforward that you know we we have
some internal predicates that
already test and say is this a valid
entity syntax because there's lots of
different things that are entities or
entity classes or properties or combined
entity class what's the typical use of
this thing in code
hdq
when would you typically use this
so other than the meta programming that
you're doing so to speak
go ahead yeah i mean i think you know
doing any sort of
operation in terms of
taking
uh results that come back from either
natural language parsing or connecting
into the knowledge base you may want to
have an arbitrary expression input and
say you know is this an entity is dated
an entity it potentially could be but
you need to
know what the the different arguments
that potentially go into it are and so i
think
i'm i'm not convinced
i think the cases where i would have
wished to have such a function would be
when i do something programmatically
say
a zip code from a country
like rather than getting them i
construct one and want to know is this a
valid one for some reason not every
integer might be a zip code in a certain
country
or
say attributes
uh that have a certain date range i
don't know like do we have the gdp
between 1640 and 1650
right so that
is
presumably as opposed to this
it's like it's not particularly useful
to know that that is syntactically an
entity
i'm not sure about that in geo for
example i have quite a few of these
checks and they are structural it's
typically for branching
i mean do i have to do this operation in
the server or do i have to
send the whole thing through a
entity related function
but the whether the entity actually
exists or not will be decided later
how do i sorry how do i determine what
this type is here
i thought there was an
entity type name
okay
okay whereas if i do that on percent one
okay so that goose is a little bit
cooked there it already thinks that's
valid enough to know what type it is
sorry so jose you were saying you check
for structural the structure before you
ever check whether the entity exists
yes because if
if it is structurally correct i'm going
to send it to entity value and then
entity value will complain if the entity
doesn't exist
and but
at least i know i have a potential
entity and there are internal functions
called possible entity queue etc which
is the type of thing i use it's the
possible version
well so
go ahead
i think both
functions will be useful so there are
cases for both of them so maybe we
should think about both use case
well i mean
is it just two use cases or are there
even more
i think the whole basically you do enter
the attribution to date it is a whole
big field
like is a dated entity a valid entity or
not
yes
yes or no variant
or the nd instance
exactly
i mean it feels like interpreter types
almost
that is
you know in an interpreter there is
something which could be a semantic
number versus a versus an actual number
etc right
there's something which designates some
kind of entity like a geo variant
versus it is on its face and entity it's
like number versus semantic number
right
i i think for me the important thing is
what is it something that i can send to
entity value
okay
to complain much later another question
what is the analog of interpreter that
tests if the thing is of that type
i think it's also
so
so i'm i don't know if it's documented
but if you
right if you do that it interprets it
because you gave it a string but if you
give it the integer maybe this isn't
what you're asking
then it spits it back but if you give it
um
um
right there we go
all right but i can see this as being a
useful thing so interpreter is mostly
taking strings
right
to me it's a very much the same kind of
thing i mean because because again as
you say there are shades of
existence-ness for entities
like if i say entity
um
you know named mosquitoes or something
we just don't have that entity type
see what i'm saying yeah
and that's a different level of failure
from that zip code doesn't exist
so coming to the invalid entity let's
say the zip code if we request a
property let's say polygon the result
will be missing unknown entity
and if the type were invalid we get
missing unknown type so
at request time we already get some
information what went wrong
yes
and in many cases
the look up is probably the only way to
determine if it's valid because
it needs non-trivial information about
the world other than
something that can be computed up really
well so maybe the right thing to think
about is
that instead of an entity q we have some
kind of entity check function
which returns various kinds of condition
codes
for the entity exists be happy or
various kinds of failures
so i was talking before this with carlo
who couldn't attend and one of the
related topics he brought up is that
entity count is a useful property in a
lot of cases for looking up information
about types or classes or
constructed classes but we don't have a
first class entity count function so
right above that section is kind of a
trivial version
of
entity count as a meta property that
exists for
each domain and is
evaluated for entity classes and we
could potentially have entity count
return
a count for a single entity of
zero if it doesn't exist or one if it
does
it's it's kind of a funky example it's a
hack i mean i think i think we would
want entity check
as well as entity count
that entity count look again entity
count is only going to
is going to only
count entities that are entity valuable
so to speak that are entity evaluatable
right
okay
so
i kind of feel that okay let's let's try
on again the idea of entity q with a
second argument
i wonder if this works so
one thing you might want to do is say
what
thing is this is this a is this an all
the way through you can evaluate it it's
an entity it has an entity value it's
all happy
or is this something which kind of fails
somewhere down the pipeline and where
does it fail down the pipeline
and you want to see the failure message
basically
from that
wannabe entity that wasn't an entity
value level entity
of
the missing flavors for the property
yes
yes so so you evaluate it
right right so
so if i say enter the zip code here
um
hello
right
so the question is for the proto for the
piece of symbolic gunk
what do i type
to get
something analogous to this
maybe like check entity similar to check
arguments
well yeah right i mean but but is it the
case
okay let's look at the flow of code
okay
is it the case that most of the time in
code you either want to get back the
entity that is this
resolved symbolic
it'll have properties type entity
i'm so confused here i think when you
get it back it's really always okay
it's kind of when you don't get it back
if you kind of cook it up yourself that
you are on shady territory right right
right but once it goes through the
evaluator it's going to either get it
back or not right
like in this case here once it went
through the evaluator either turned into
the the yellow
entity or it didn't
and one of the things that you're sort
of complaining about is there's no
programmatic way to test what did it
turn into because this yellow entity in
fact yeah yeah here's the point here's
the point the input form of this
is the same thing isn't it
that's always about to say i don't think
it has anything to do with the evaluator
it's yes
it's a typesetting issue yeah i i know
that i know that but what i'm saying is
what i'm saying is there is no
programmatic way to find out is this
yellow on my screen
someone said no we're not uh
you call make boxes and look inside
yes michael i know but what i'm saying
is if you've got yeah this is the number
of the problem okay
the the this thing here
right as far as does it have head entity
oh yeah it has a head entity it's all
good just like this one has had entity
what didn't happen here and that we need
a programmatic thing to check is
whatever the thing that caused this to
be you know
valid entity cue or something
needs to return true or false for
whether it will come back
as a yellow box thing that has an entity
value
i i would say you could cheat you could
say format value of invalid entity equal
and then you get a yellow one back yet
it's nice
michael you're being too literal about
the yellow thing okay i i was i was
gonna ask
um as i check if uh oh and the answer is
apparently no canonical name i guess
actually works on the invalid entity so
that's not a good check
it could be also an entity exists queue
right like file exists
okay that's a possibility
right but the main point which i think
is correctly being raised is
you can't tell
if i make yeah i mean this is a great
example with zip codes if i make a table
of entity
you know zip code
and i probably need to say
um
two string i
you know i goes from six thousand
whatever it is sixty thousand to sixty
thousand
two you know and fifty
oops
sorry i think common name works common
name on the invalid one returns a
missing unknown entity and it returns
okay that's absolutely sure but what we
need to know here
um
is
but it's i think it's slightly more
tricky because for the built-in one i
think this will work in the direction
you go but for an entity store that up
said you set up yourself you don't have
to fill out all the properties and then
some of them might be not there and it
might still be a valid entity
okay
[Music]
look this is a valid question is the
thing an entity
that look in an entity store there
either it is either listed as an entity
or it isn't correct
okay so this is the question of
i don't know whether exists is the right
word existence is a complicated concept
but but look you've got to be able to
have something which i can run you know
what can i run on this list
which will determine which ones are
yellow and i mean that only
in a way to i don't literally mean that
so to speak i mean yeah ones happen to
format as yellow in this case versus
which ones were not found
so and there's maybe another thing to
consider uh q functions should return a
boolean but while looking up that
veteran entity exists something might go
wrong
and there might be an intermittent
failure
so
yes
yes actually i feel like a conceptually
more difficult one
we have the concept of the empty seat
entity classes and also of implicit
entities
an implicit entity say you want an
avocado
that has a calories for more than
fifty thousand kilo calories per gram is
this a valid entity or not
right i understand that doesn't happen
to exist
this is michael in the you know
necessary versus contingent truth
question yeah it is a contingent truth
about the world whether there exists an
avocado exactly with that with those
characteristics
but kendall you could write it down and
nicely formatted yellow
but it doesn't happen to exist in the
world exactly
i don't think we care it's just like a
zip code
well let me think let me think about
that for a second
one thing is okay so a zip code
unallocated by the u.s postal service
and therefore not turning yellow
why is that different from an avocado
that has more calories than avocado can
have
because like this one is an absolute
listing but the other one you need
implicit entities to even pull it off
so you're saying an implicit entity
where you're asking for zip codes whose
name happens to be six seven eight one
two yes would be a valid exactly yeah
that's my point yeah good good
pullback jeremy
sorry i'm sorry what were you just
saying could you repeat that
instead of
the zip code with um
the zip code that is uh six seven eight
one two
it's
the zip codes
whose standard name is six seven eight
one two
like can you turn this one which doesn't
exist into an implicit one right and
then the existence question becomes much
harder
i see
so i see your your point is
that just like i can test the avocado
i could also implicitly test for zip
codes whose numbers were between this
and this yeah
so it really is a question of does it in
on your on its face exist or not
as opposed to it's a contingent fact
about the world where somebody might you
know at the next county fair they might
grow an avocado that has that energy
density or whatever
um
just like the us postal service might
allocate another zip code
so i think what this is is
does the entity
what is this
francisco center this is kind of the
entity version
okay
i see so so then the question is for
consistency they should be basically
either both exist or both not exist
well so now if i go here and i say
entity list
the heck is that going to do so that
well i'm so confused here
why is this so slow
because i'm taking it
yeah like in the first case because we
see from the table above that the
60 000 doesn't exist no no i know that
but why was it so slow to come back that
was what i was complaining about
okay i understand why this is doing this
okay so this is not resolvable
okay so the implicit entity on its face
is constructable
but it doesn't happen to exist in the
world yeah which is like your avocado
it's it's a little bit like a
non-measurable set once you allow
implicit construction you could write
down
implicit regions that have
where you can't say if they have
measures or not
yeah i understand
well so then what this has to be the
test that's useful then
okay there are two levels of tests that
are probably useful
i mean one is drill all the way and find
out if it ultimately exists
as a resolvable thing
and the other is
oh boy
the other which seems less useful
is is it is it a well-formed entity uh
thing right so there's there's is it
well-formed and then does it exist in
the world
making sense yeah
which is actually in what's that i know
what you mean
right this is it is the difference
between a well-formed formula and
mathematical logic and a true a
well-formed statement and a true
statement yeah exactly yeah
we have similar cases with
files and audio files which are out of
core things like that
do we i don't think we have the notion
of a well-formed file name particularly
well but what i mean is that well that's
why we have file exists skew more than
file q i think to avoid this problem of
we have a well-formed file name but made
point i see
i see
or audi i was looking how audio queue is
phrased
and it says it has the form of a valid
audio object
yeah i think there's plenty of these
like graphq and things like that that
just
might be slightly different because
they're atomic so they have yet another
level of complications
we have quantity q which looks up
whether the unit actually exists in
addition to syntax checks
okay and what does it do it says false
if the unit doesn't exist
is that correct
does it give a message
that too yes
that's weird
only the message is coming from the
evaluating quantity which complains
i see
but there's another case uh to enlighten
that discussion
going into direction of entity classes
then we can also ask whether an entity
class exists
and when we then distinguish between
named entity classes they can clearly
exist or not exist by
we knowing we knowing the name there's
also implicit entity classes and then
the question is
does this implicit entity class exist
what does exist mean does it mean it's
the null set if it if it is a perfectly
well-formed thing but it happens to ask
for planets close to the sun the mercury
and it says there aren't any right
exactly yeah it's the same question yeah
um
so i mean i think that's like michael's
prize avocado
that is the the the um
it is a
it is a question that we can answer
about the world
there may or may not be an entity that
is there that really exists in the world
but is the question we can answer about
the world
as opposed to something which is
essentially
where the meaning is not defined in
other words that the lo okay so the
levels are
syntactically well-formed
okay the next level is
uh
references
something that could exist in the world
well references
okay asks a well-defined question about
the world
amenable to experimental investigation
so to speak
and then the next thing is
there is actually
there is actually a thing
that quotes answers that question
is that right
so for example
it is a well-defined question about the
world
oh my gosh
i think that the third one definitely
doesn't i feel like the difference
between the first and the second is a
little bit fuzzy
i don't agree i think this syntactically
well formed is very well defined that is
you can have an implicit entity class
specification look if your thing was
you know what's the population of the
avocado
that's not well well-formed
shoot it's not really syntactic is it no
but it could be syntactic in the sense
that you can have that as an attribute
right in the book
but it's not a valid attribute in that
case but we don't have any attribute
only for the attribute
okay but syntactically okay there's
another level which is
syntactically pure syntax actual
language syntax
syntactically well-formed
but
uh
basically referring to entities
what is the right way to say it but
it's whether
okay for example but eg
referring to properties that don't exist
for that type of entity
in other words it's going to fail
how would it be failing if it's asking
for an entity class of avocados with
population more than a thousand
i don't know i didn't that's even
confusing even as i say that in natural
language but where where the gdp of the
no no even that's confusing because it
might be the you know farmers growing
avocados but anyway let's say
the
the
avocado has um
how many
how many hit records the avocado has had
that clearly is
presumably not a thing that is a valid
kind of property for chicago
okay so then the question is what is
that what type of a failure is that
and is that
a so i mean that's a that's a property
mismatch failure
i mean this is so reminiscent of the the
traditional you know philosophical logic
thing
you know
i the most famous version of that is the
king of france is bald
probably from a different era but you
know at a time when there wasn't a king
of france
right what does that what is the that
thing fails to reference anything
right and so this is a
this is a fails
fail yeah that's the point this is fails
to reference anything
versus
this one here
where
it asks like for example
is the president of france you know
whatever it is right if there is a
president then that's a well-defined
question about the world and you can go
and observe whether they're left or
right-handed or whatever it is
right so it's a different thing so this
is a this is a failure of reference
um
and
right so i think this is the point these
are the levels
you know syntax let's save this file
somewhere oh it doesn't save where am i
supposed to save this
um
where does this go
entity framework i guess we'll put it
there
um
for now at least it's not a great place
for it okay so i think the levels are
syntactically okay
claims levels
are
syntactically correct syntactically well
formed
next
fails to reference
anything
reference failure third is
um
references something
potentially
it
fails to reference something
because
right it
tells to meaningfully reference anything
this one is i mean it
references something potentially
references something
but needs experimental verification so
to speak
and then the final one is
we can actually nail we can
identify
in the system an actual entity
an actual built-in you know an actual
entity in the entity store or whatever
right does that does that make sense and
then
so in other words
here's an example
a dated version of the ukraine
two years ahead
doesn't fall in any of these i would
argue
i claim it's it's category three
it potentially references something
but it can't be experimentally verified
well i said it wrong though
i think it's more complicated if it
referenced ukraine during the soviet
period when the country didn't exist
it's a similar version yeah
but the question is whether
whether that means
that's the king of france type question
yeah
um
i'm being asked to make it larger i i
don't really want to do that because
there should be ways to zoom in better
it's just really hard to
and it's too big it's really hard to
work with it
i always use this hundred percent
question of the site
what's that
in the
upper
menu of zoom yeah i know there's people
watching on the live stream also
um
the uh
okay so again let's go through this
again
first point is it's clear entity queue
needs several levels
it's not going to get away with just one
level
okay so michael is is talking about
okay so i mean let's consider the case
i don't know why we pick on ukraine but
let's pick on ukraine
um
okay so the first question i changed
quickly
oh no
uh
okay
so these are different cases
okay
what is the status
okay let's take ukraine 1975.
boy this is complicated
to me the important difference is
between the first one and the other
three
the first one is some sort of possible
entity queue and the other ones are
entity with some second argument say
and and the main thing is that is
whether you need to go to data tables
to databases
well yeah this is this is need to look
up data yeah
and this one might be but but no that
one probably isn't that one that's need
to
and needs much smaller tables
right it needs to look up metadata
to decide that
right if the property exists if the
attribute exists something like that
right but it will still take some time
it's not as fast as a few values in the
first one
to check heads and strings
but kind of like for at least for the
building in principle if you could have
such tables
quickly yes yes
okay i think this is a very good
distinction are you looking at metadata
or are you looking up data
right and now for the ukraine 1975 that
is not determinable from metadata
right right
that requires actual data
um
i like this distinction
um
okay so a minute you need to look
updated to determine it
and the final one is
okay well hold on a second so so this
one is
it fails
you look up the metadata and it fails in
this case
okay then this one here is you look up
the metadata
and it passes
but you didn't let look up the data
and then the final one as you looked up
the data and it was okay
right
i think this is a pretty good good
collection
now they need names
so we need to handle this sort of
separate distinction like
there's another case that's not like the
preposterous avocado but say
buildings in champaign with a floor
count under three
which
we probably don't have any entities for
that but there are certainly many
of those entities in the world there are
things that are sort of out of scope for
our coverage particular entity type but
they
they do exist we need to be clear that
entity exists q is saying whether that
entity exists in our knowledge base and
not that it exists
i should just say
well i mean that would be
that would be a type three in this in
this in our classification that's a type
three
but you're right that the naming should
not suggest that
the fact that we fail to hit type 4
implies that in other words
the the failure to nail type 4 does not
actually mean in certain cases
that it's like a thing we we were trying
to do that that project i don't know
whatever happened to it for from alpha
of questions that we know can't be
answered
what happened to that project michael it
never was really seriously started
is it a good idea
i don't think so i think we don't
encounter them frequently enough
okay but that's but but i mean okay so
that relates to this it's questions that
could never seriously be answered
like what's the smallest lake in
minnesota
right such a question is just not
it does it it's just fine in metadata it
reaches type level three here but it
cannot reach level four
so okay so we've also got the
the um the level here which is
essentially the smallest lake in
minnesota level
i've got to be able to spell minnesota i
think that's a slightly different one
from ellen's one because we will have a
smallest lake in minnesota
it might not be the ones that
i see point of view
without the
the two-story houses is a different
story
so to speak
yeah
um
well we're pretty sure they exist well i
mean i don't think we can know
i mean we have we have some hand like
i'm struggling to find an example of
this right now but i thought we had put
up some support in some domains in alpha
where if you
if you ask questions like this
there's some footnote that comes back
that sort of gives a hint that
we don't we don't claim to think that we
have every possible thing of this type
and it's not it's not just that we say
you know notable buildings or books or
things to sort of fudge on our coverage
it's that there's an explicit note
somewhere i'm trying to find some place
where this comes back
i think there are some austral classes
like the twitter mastermind
well asteroids is far far smaller
than the real mess so for the real mess
we have a different value than the sum
of its parts
okay what are we going to do with this
so
this is some kind of
i mean maybe there's a function entity
check
which basically
where you can give it
what what will we like it to return we
would like i mean we might like it to
return which of these levels it reached
the alternative would be to have like
success versus failure results where we
could say
you know
if it may be less entity check but like
entity validate or something could say
yes this is
successfully identified down to an
actually existing entity
or if it fails then we have some
it failed because it's syntactically
well-formed but doesn't have a
meaningful reference okay so what we
could do here
is entity validate
gives a failure object by default gives
a failure object unless it reaches the
end of this uh you know chain
but then
for many things that's too expensive you
want to do less
right
well
i see so you don't even want to try
right you only want to go up to step two
at most
right
well okay second argument here right
yeah but the question is what does the
second argument do so if this is
returning i kind of like the idea of
returning success and failure
potentially although it's a bit of a
nuisance to have to do okay so it's
entity validate entity check
one of these kinds of things but then
what does entity validate so if that
returns success and failure
the default case will be you run it all
the way
and then this case will be let's say you
run it to
metadata check or something
you run just to metadata
um
then that would validate
validate the metadata
and then we could say
um
entity validate for data
well what that will be which one is this
let's see
you look up the metadata and it fails so
that's you look up the metadata and it
what's this level here
but you didn't look up the data yet
i see so that that would return success
if the metadata was okay
right so that's that's the distinction
okay so then right then the first form
here
is
entity value and then this just says
syntax
okay so that's does it pass the first
one so that returns success if it's
syntactically correct
and if it fails out at the first level
it's failure
this one
limit that one
the next one here metadata if it fails
at this level it kicks it out and it
gives failure otherwise it says success
and this one okay so this one is success
on metadata
limit
so this one isn't isn't isn't explicitly
in this list
does it need to be am i confused
is this a fence post problem of how many
how many different categories we need
here i think it is i think we only need
three
for a normal entity like a zip code the
first and second that the syntax
metadata would be the same right
so there are three predicates here
the first is
entity q which means a variable x can be
formatted as an entity which means it's
syntactically reformed
second no no no no no that's not correct
the second is
uh entity property exists which means no
no no no
no we've been talking about a zillion
other cases that aren't what you just
described
the fact that it's formatible has
nothing to do with whether it's
syntactic correct just look at this
example here okay
right
so let's go back to this okay so is it
syntactically correct we i think we all
understand what that means
do you agree
michael allen francisco other people
here
okay
okay this is
is its metadata
correct that is you test whether
the metadata that it
refers to like do the properties match
the entities and so on that is primarily
relevant
for implicit entities uh and will that
check also the entity type
i think so yes yes it would it will it
will check things which are checkable
without ever looking at any data they
look at they're checkable by looking at
the backbone of the entity store
yeah without looking at it
so so there is one more thing we could
do a given a property we could check
whether the data
that we give as constraint matches the
property type now that means a
population needs to be
constrained to numbers
i see
wait a minute so so wait a minute so
that's for an implicit entity class
that's an additional case
um this is checking both metadata and
it's the metadata it's like the
dimensions of the property value i feel
like it's metadata okay so you think
that should be included in the metadata
level
and see craig on the live stream is
talking about tree form of energy check
but i don't understand
joe where things failed
i don't see why because it depends what
it returns i mean in other words
by the way this here
well okay the question of whether it
okay whether we even need
failure objects as opposed to just true
false for this
do you get what i'm saying
i think i think that by default it
should return true false and maybe
there's a third argument which says what
it should return
and what about passing through any valid
entity
i see like like the
so in other words
okay
so i see i see i see so so entity
validate could be something which is
entity validate could return either
the entity blah blah blah
could return either the entity
or
a failure object that's what you're
suggesting right
yes
so that you just wrap entity okay and
then what you could do
then the code would look like confirm
of entity validate
of entity
blah blah blah
that would be kind of nice
i agree that that's pretty nice
it could be called entity check in the
sense that check is does precisely that
letting things pass if correct
yes
i mean i wonder if this should be a form
of con no it shouldn't be a form of
confirm
but does entity just check return
failure objects no
check
was
25 years before failure objects
no but check the returns but whatever
you put in the
next arguments right right
so the fact that it defaults to failure
it's fine i guess
fair enough fair enough
fair enough so so i mean this could have
a third argument which is what to return
so i do like the idea of having it just
return the entity but now
but but we also want something which is
just a select where you can put it in
select
like for those for those zip codes for
instance
right
right a true false version that could be
used in selecting patterns etc
right
um so maybe we want two things here we
want entity queue and entity check
i kind of like entity validate because
it suggests it's doing more work
because it is doing quite a lot of work
in many cases
and i don't like the check because i
think of check
as um
working with messages not
yeah so i think entity validate is good
um
and then maybe we could have i mean we
could just have entity validated entity
valid q or something or entity validated
queue
as the queue form of this
oh i see craig is commenting the user
would want to know where it failed like
a zip code
four five three one oh blah blah blah
might be partially valid zip code
that's in the failure right
no it isn't there because the fact is
but but the partially evaluated is the
data it's not the representation issue
yes this is about representation but the
one thing we're not giving people here
is
if you
let's say you want to know did it fail
syntax metadata data level
yeah we can put it in the failure object
so that the default entity val validate
goes all the way through
but returns a failure object saying at
what level it failed so if you want to
know what level it failed you can just
pick up the failure object
um
all right so i think what we're thinking
about is entity validate an entity
validated queue
what does the q function return when
the server connection fails c
well let me point out that this is going
to need
a time constraint
blah blah blah
default to infinity
see what i'm saying
yes
so the answer is
the entity validated q could have a
non-infinite time constraint
and that's just returning whatever it
could return in the available time
does anyone know what file exists queue
does if it's trying to check on like a
network drive in the network drive time
that's a good question i was wondering
that i'm guessing it's a similar sort of
yeah and i don't know what it does but
let's
it's see sparse on details
we better ask that question does anybody
here know does constantin perhaps know
here
yeah
so um
may yeah i'm not sure actually
um
the metadata level would be also an
interesting
president for well from language
expressions
like we have syntax code to check if the
syntax over all is okay but we don't
have a function to take an overlay that
plot with a bunch of
non-existing options and non-existing
right-hand sides to validate yeah this
is an interesting idea
that's relevant to code assistance too
but that's what
parser does in some cases right so so it
checks
no it doesn't no no
no
no no the point is the path that the
syntactic part of it can pass
i mean the parser tools
oh you mean the limiting system yes
absolutely that's what that does
it's a very complicated world
um
all right this is very good i think guys
why don't we you go ahead um another
question
so this function would take anything
like an entity an entity property
an entity class
basically the entity would fight
anything in the entity world right i
think so what about the lists of
entities
yes
because it is sufficient to validate a
long list of entities more than doing
one by one
yeah well actually the way this is
working is that will be fine
entity validate okay the only question
is if you give it a list
is it listable and does it put a few
failure objects in or just just stick
its tongue out and give you a single
failure object if anything failed i
think it's purely listable
are you sure
i think as tony just said i think it
will be for many applications i want to
do it fast but i won't
they did three in my list of hundred
thousand i know i have to take care
somehow differently i see
like your list of uh zip codes above
exactly
it would be great that you could return
the list of the entities plus some
failure objects there
okay okay i agree all right okay and the
default case with one argument with the
data case
right go all the way yeah i think so
okay
um does it need any other options other
than time constraint it might need an
option it might need a third argument
which is what's a return if things fail
and
in other words
instead of returning a failure it could
be a function to wrap around well i
don't know i don't know exactly
there's there's a question of whether it
could give you more information in the
metadata failure it probably can
about exactly how it failed
craig is suggesting a tree but i i the
thing is we just don't have that level
of information here there's so many
bizarre things that can happen
we just can't guarantee to give a very
well structured
you know description of the failure i
mean this is okay interesting discussion
i was talking to christopher about this
actually recently and it's a discussion
that we need to get into i'll be i guess
okay this is this is slightly off topic
but i think it's perhaps interesting
it's the notion of
uh
okay you write a piece of code it's
supposed to do something
then there is the error case where
something went wrong how much code do
you write around the error case
typically the programmer there is a
decaying amount of effort put into the
error cases and as which is correct
because the error cases should be rare
okay so the question is
what we're talking about is the notion
of something that is
some kind of guarded evaluate
that
basically
because because in in general
you know what is an error case is one
over zero an error that should cause
execution of the program to stop
is
it an error when some numerical scheme
doesn't converge
adequately right some of these require
you know for some purposes
if you discover that something in your
code has gone even slightly wrong you
want to exit everything
right because you're you know do you
launch the rocket or not if the
numerical scheme failed to converge that
tells you something you probably don't
want to launch the rocket at that time
it's better to not do anything
does that make sense whereas in other
cases you just want to barrel forward
even though there might be few error
messages generated
and the point that i was trying to make
here
is the thing to understand is
it's hard enough to write a program let
alone to write a program that handles
every error case and people just don't
do it and so what you have to do is
either bank
control you know just say if there's any
error just quit
or you have to say let's just barrel
forward and hope the errors don't don't
accumulate and mess us up
and i think it's the same type of thing
here there are many different kinds of
errors that can occur and writing you
know what we're providing here is
another level of sort of uh
transparency about what
possible erroring is happening but we
can't expect to provide a full language
of errors so to speak
did that make sense
i don't know michael well yeah right i
think so i think so
i think it's an important concept this
this calculus of errors so to speak and
i don't mean in the sense of a round
i mean i mean you know given that you
have a piece of code and it went off
track
what do you do and how do you you know
can you symbolically represent the way
that it went off track
because messages are a very coarse way
to represent the way in which uh code
went off track
and so that's what's being asked for
here so let's just let's just turn that
stone over one more time of you know is
there anything more that we can say here
about what went off track so if somebody
said return a symbolic object that
represents what went off track when you
were doing this metadata lookup what
could you do
i don't understand well enough how that
method is lookup is being done
right for example you can say if the
entity type was the thing wrong or the
properties referenced were wrong okay
fine you can you can certainly do that
but by the time you're more encrusted
inside an entity implicit entity class
to what extent can you unravel and say
this is where it went wrong
i i think you can because either the
entity type one of the properties or the
dimensions of the property values one of
them must have confirmed this moment
because this all the metadata that we
will have okay so let me ask this
question is it a one-shot error as in
it's just a message that says this or
that or is there a non-trivial domain
specific language that represents the
error condition
that's actually already implemented on
alpha and
and when users specify such a class and
request values they get detailed
missings with all of those this
information inside you know it's one
missing it's not a tree
but for for one entity many many reasons
could exist like could have 20
properties specified in implicitly none
and you could have 20 good ones where
you have on the right hand side values
that are not appropriate
so there might be many many reasons not
just one right so so we need some okay
so it would be nice to have some
representation of what went wrong
the probably some something like five
different kinds of cases and then
you just have to specify which position
they happened let's say the invalid
property of a query yeah then there you
have to find a property or name the
property that has that caused this error
fair enough although there might be
multiple places where that property was
referenced
yes
but but that's
something for for you to look up right
but on the other hand
we could argue we stop at the first
invalid property
that's a good point
so therefore it's like syntax q
well i don't syntax length tells you how
long it was syntactically correct for
before it errored out
yeah
well okay have a think about this but
this this seems like a very good
direction here
so we had a couple of questions on the
comments on the live stream here
um let's look at those for a second and
then we probably have to wrap up um
this was a useful conversation even
though i thought this was going to be a
trivial conversation but that absolutely
was not
um
right
ally on our live streams commenting
depends if the error is in a critical
piece of code
and he says like and integrate well
he may for him and integrate may be
critical but for other people if there's
a convergence failure in an integrate
it's like well i'll get the best i can
and that's probably fine and i won't
worry about it but for other you know
one person's
little knit is another person's
disastrous error and that's one of the
issues in error handling is it depends
on what you need what you need it for
like for example
you know it is super common that i'll be
doing sort of research programming so to
speak and i will generate all kinds of
you know things where there was a
special case where there was a null list
and everything went wrong and i just
don't care because i'm just looking for
the cases you know i know oh yeah there
was some corner case i didn't handle it
just doesn't matter even though i'm
generating tons of messages and so on i
absolutely do not want it to stop and
quit
just because it generated one you know
one message
um okay there's a comment here from
ethan about
references and and
source citations and so on um
don't what do we have in the language we
certainly have that involved from alpha
what do we have in the language
if you say gdp of whatever
and you want to know
uh you know
it's basically going to be a link back
to a web page that has you know because
it's typically we've processed this data
in all kinds of ways so it's basically
you know
it's um
uh let's pick on the ukraine here
how would we get
in
from
the language can we get source
information
there's a third argument to entity value
exactly
so i don't know about that i think
source here
yeah so if you have that where do i put
it can i please
entity value oh in the second argument
no i i don't think so that works too oh
just comma string scores
there we go
what's that
i think it's a source wow it's a source
entity
yeah
is that exposed in like excel
in
our are those exposed there
in excel no the way we've handled the
sourcing there is we
we put a link into the cards there that
sends them back to our source pages for
giving
i see
um
okay
uh
okay
um
let's see what we i think i think that
is
probably all we
have a chance to do okay so that's a
great answer for the source thing
um oh there was a comment from ali here
which i just want to
uh look at
this is really irrelevant to our current
discussion but
it's a question of of putting in a part
specification
is there a way of
wait a minute
of not using part you know there is a
case here where
i want to know
where is the maximum element in a list
for example how do i find that out
i mean what i usually do is i compute
max and i do position a bit no we can do
take largest we do you remember the
arrow position notation with index
oh i forgot that
yeah you use the largest of some list of
numbers arrow
index
that's
it's a bad sign that i forgot it
okay so
are all
where
this here yes
yeah that's and now two or something
two comma two
well that's a little bit obscure
you can say instead of all you can say
index
so this is the notation that we use here
to extract several things at the same
time without having to go through
several passes and it's also used in
nearest
now i know it's used in nearest i forgot
that it was used in tech largest i want
to bring back this discussion okay
okay um
and what ali is suggesting here is a
thing where
which i don't know this notation is not
going to make it but
um something like this
in other words how do you reset
given a list
i mean this is a mutable operator i mean
this is a mutation and that's a
different thing which we've been
discussing separately from mutations but
but um
and that looks like fortran syntax by
the way
oh really you can do that in fortran you
couldn't do that in 4chan when i was
using 4chan
not even close
in some of these 2 000
versions i think it wasn't
ok and fortran 2100 or something you'll
be able to do
all kinds of stuff
um
the uh
i think it's encouraging that these
old languages are still around although
um
you know at the time when fortran was
built the constraints were just utterly
different
we're very lucky that our language was
built at a time when the constraints
were just about falling away
um anyway
uh okay anything else we should cover
right now today i mean we're not we're
going to
we'll have to cover these a different
time
and i really would like to get that
error handling guarded evaluate
discussion on the books
um
okay anything else for right now
nope nope okay i should do it
thanks a lot thanks